100天入文量化
接下来我们用量期快速学习一些杂七杂八的指标
前面我给大家讲过了MACD、KDJ、布林显、DMI、RSI、SAR、CCI、OBV、VR
他们这些指标的大原理基本已经覆改了主流指标了
其他指标大多数都是在他们的基础上改的
我用量期带大家快速过一遍
BIS很多人都见过 它的名字叫做乖立志
好家伙听起来很高大上对吧
但公式其实很简单
就是当天的收盘价减去近期的均价
得出来的就是今天的收盘价
比平时的均价高了还是低了
差了多少
用这个差值除以近期的均价
其实就相当于得出来了今天的涨幅和跌幅
用今天的涨跌幅乘上100就是管理值
正管理就是今天的价格比均价高
副管理就是今天的价格比均价低
就是这么简单
跟MACD其实是一个道理
什么乖离
那不就是MACD里面的离叉吗
WR微连指标
我们在讲KDJ的课里面讲过了支撑力RSA
这个微连指标就是用100减去RSA你可以把它简单理解为压力值阻力值就行如果把它带入到KDJ的公式里面就可以做出一个完全相反的指标出来
唐吉安指标跟布林线长得很像
上下各划了一根线
它这两根线在一般的软件里面
都是指最近20天的最大值和最小值
最大值在上面 最小值在下面
上下的周期都是能修改的
不停线是均值思维
唐其安通道就是极限思维
还有一些其他的通道指标
大家的思路无外乎就是这两种
均值和极限
还有PSY指标
它叫做心理线
就是用上涨天数除以下跌的天数
乘100求出来的
比如说最近12天
8天上涨4天下跌
那先用8除以4等于2再乘上100
那PSY就是200
6天找6天跌呢
那就是100
就是这么简单
所有的基础面就是个观察市场方式
就是快速用几个数字告诉你
过去几天发生了啥
你就不用去数了去算了
还有一些变种的均值和价差指标
听起来很高大上
但其实来回就是变些变量
逻辑上跟我之前讲的那些经典指标没有区别
今天这些指标你学到了吗